to plenty of observers 1990s the bonfire
of the vanities must have looked like a
slam dunk director Brian De Palmer was
coming off a string of hits and the
movie was based on a best-selling novel
by Tom Wolfe it also starred some big
names like Tom Hanks Bruce Willis and
Morgan Freeman but it didn't turn out
quite so well as it made back just 50
million dollars of its 47 million dollar
Budget on top of the disappointing box
office bonfire was also nominated for
five golden raspberry Awards including
Melanie Griffith and Kim Cattrall for
worst actress and the worst supporting
actress respectively speaking about the
movie years later hence admitted that
part of the reason for its failure was
that everyone in the film including
himself was miscast he also made it
clear that translating the book itself
to the screen was simply too challenging